I watching this um I've seen both of
them with audiences and I feel like this
one there were so many more like hmm
they're wearing my gosh oh yeah
throughout the point I almost couldn't
hear what was going on and what we're
everything so why do you think that
would be I think this one is a little
bit more heightened everything is a
little bit more intense whether it's the
emotion the relationships the new
characters the sex scenes everything is
a little bit more wild
I was cast five weeks before we started
filming the first one yeah I didn't have
a lot of time with it and I feel that
this time up said plenty more time for
whatever reason there was a little bit
more freedom in terms of what I wanted
to do with it and I lied to put my stamp
on it a little bit more I think and and
II know I just make him I wanted to make
him a bit more human make him more
attractive I didn't yeah I'm warm him up
a bit and it's nice to see me smile and
stuff I've always sort of been curious
is it the relationship and his obsession
with her that women sort of are so drawn
to or is it the sex for me it was a
relationship that's what everyone says I
mean it's not the sex that gets it's the
perfect where am i if not reading it it
had a love story I mean that's what
people say it's just a lobster because
you can read countless books that are
full of sex it's actually the love story
of these of these people and you're
rooting for them to be together you
understand why they're not and you
understand up there he's such a pain no
we don't release your Michael later and
vehicle you know is a bloke so yeah I
think that I think that loads so that's
that that's what it is if you're going
to set the tone for the night and
they're going to make it a fifty shades
darker night what should they do before
which they do after what's your
recommended viewing situation my
approach should be to drink before and
drink after I think it's an exciting
from experience and usually things are
more exciting and more fun when you're
pissed you're not Irish or anything on
them
ya know it's given us a good name right
now
it's something were to happen to you I
could never forgive myself
[Music]
you